the second season of the umbrella
academy follows the hargreaves siblings
as they navigate an unfamiliar decade
fraught with challenges
it's a lot to keep track of and if you
reach the end of season two a little
fuzzy on some of the details
we're here to help lila is introduced as
a fellow patient at the mental hospital
where diego is sent
after he attempts to kill lee harvey
oswald and prevent
the assassination of john f kennedy
after helping diego escape and earning
his trust
we learned that she is actually a time
traveler herself we also learned that
her mother is the handler who adopted
her after the commission killed her
parents
in 1993. her backstory gets even more
complicated than that though
it turns out that the handler orders the
murders of lila's parents
because she knew about lila's special
abilities lila was born on october 1st
1989
just like all of the hargreaves siblings
as the result of one of the 43
mysterious pregnancies and births that
we learned about at the beginning of the
series
hargreaves adopted seven of the babies
but the other 36
remained a mystery until lila like the
hargreaves siblings
lila has her own unique powers she can
mimic anyone else's power
turning their own abilities back on them
like a weaponized
mirror which explains why the handler
wanted to claim her as her own
when the hargreaves clan arrived in the
1960s they all assumed the world is safe
until 2019 when vanya would blow up the
moon and annihilate all life on earth
however when five arrives in dallas in
1963
he witnesses the last moments of his
siblings final stand against a soviet
invasion
before an arsenal of nuclear missiles
wipes them all out
obviously this was a different version
of 1963 than the one in our history
books which leads five to conclude that
his siblings had somehow
caused the apocalypse over the 10 days
leading up to november 25th 1963
five and the other hargreaves siblings
desperately attempt to piece together
the events
leading to doomsday eventually it's
diego who uncovers the event that leads
to nuclear war
an explosion at the fbi building in
dallas which is blamed on the ussr
the u.s then attacks soviet-backed cuba
leading the ussr to bomb
anchorage alaska which leads to all-out
war
however it wasn't the soviets who caused
the explosion
but vanya when vanya uses her powers to
attempt to break through a police
blockade
she is taken into fbi custody after the
agents determined she must be a russian
operative
she's interrogated using electric shocks
the shocks cause her powers to overload
and she sends out a massive energy wave
killing the fbi agents and ultimately
causing the explosion
the first thing vanya does upon arriving
in 1963
is get hit by a car driven by [ __ ] who
subsequently brings vanya home to her
farm to recuperate
vanya has amnesia but gradually begins
to rediscover her powers throughout the
season
in episode 4 banya is pushed to use her
powers in a big way
when sissy's son harlan runs into a lake
and sinks out of sight
using her powers to lift the water out
of the lake vanya is able to carry
harlan to safety
she then uses cpr to attempt to revive
him while also unintentionally passing
some of her powers to harlan
at first vanya doesn't notice anything
different about harlan
but gradually she begins to suspect that
he's now capable of superhuman feats
later we see the extent of harlan's
borrowed power when he becomes upset
after accidentally killing his father
and unleashes an energy vortex that
freezes the whole farm
eventually vanya is able to get close
enough to harlan
to transfer his power back to herself or
so she thinks
the last we see of harlan he's making a
small toy bird levitate in his hand
implying that he still retains some of
vania's power
recognizing that the hargrave siblings
desperately want to return to their own
time
the handler strikes a deal with five she
says she'll give him a commission
briefcase that will transport him
and his siblings back to an apocalypse
free 2019
if five will agree to assassinate the
commission's board of directors
five agrees although the handler
exploits a loophole in their deal
that makes it impossible for the
hargreaves clan to travel back to 2019
as planned
once the board of directors is gone the
handler bypasses the chain of command
and assumes control of the commission
then promptly reassigns all of its field
agents to wage
war on five and his siblings vanya kills
all of the agents
and the handler herself is killed by
disgruntled field agent axel
who then leaves the commission and
strikes out on his own
after that absent the commission's prior
leadership the remaining members of the
organization vote to
put mild-mannered analyst herb in charge
we don't know what the future of the
commission holds
but without its previous leadership or
any of its field agents
it's bound to look very different in
their attempts to figure out what their
adopted father reginald hargreaves has
to do with the assassination of john f
kennedy
five and diego head to their future
father's umbrella factory
to see what they can learn while there
five comes across an invitation to a
gala hosted by hoyt hillen coder
whom helpful 60s conspiracy theorist
elliott tells them as a member of the
majestic 12.
he goes on to explain it's a a secret
committee
a scientist military a deep state no one
knows what they really do
wait so their government shadow
government
although only 11 have been identified
five and diego believe that reginald
hargreaves must
be the 12th member sure enough after
kennedy is assassinated
hargreaves meets with the majestic 12
who admit
that they orchestrated the assassination
to stop kennedy from frying into their
organization
however hargreaves is upset our little
kennedy problem was solved
he was not to be touched that was the
deal
when the twelve then threatened to
expose hargreaves alien identity if he
doesn't continue giving them his
advanced technology
he removes his human disguise and
presumably kills them all
when the hargreave siblings finally
arrived back in 2019
they're initially relieved to find that
it's april 2nd
the day after the world ended in their
original timeline
but they quickly realized that doomsday
isn't the only thing that's changed
the umbrella academy is now the sparrow
academy
their father and ben are still alive and
there are a new group of siblings living
in the mansion
who don't seem to recognize the original
six what the siblings failed to take
into consideration
was that their presence in the 1960s
would irrevocably alter the timeline
their actions impacted a number of
people outside themselves
such as the members of klaus's cult the
other activists who worked with allison
and the fbi agents that vanya killed
additionally
they made contact with their father and
told him some of what the future held
which could in turn have affected his
future actions
so while doomsday never occurred all
sorts of other parts of the timeline
were also
changed thanks to the hargreaves's
interference in the past
making the future they returned to
unrecognizable
from the one they left check out one of
our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite netflix shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one